the push continues to get more clark
county residents vaccinated good
afternoon thanks for joining us at four
on this friday i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian cassette as well
a big announcement today from the
southern nevada health district about
a drive up vaccine clinic coming to the
area
victoria saha is live in north las vegas
with what you need to know
about this new initiative victoria
[Music]
this push is to make it as easy as
possible for you to get vaccinated
starting on may 11th all you have to do
is pull up to texas station on rancho
drive in lake mead
and get your coven 19 vaccine
in a health district meeting this
morning leaders say we are at a critical
point when it comes to encouraging
residents
to get vaccinated they're hoping this
drive up clinic will help
close the gap for those who are still
deciding to get vaccinated
the drive up clinic will start tuesday
may 11th and will last about six weeks
according to dr fuhrman legend with the
health district vaccinating 1200 people
a day
is the goal so we can get closer to
having 60 percent of the community
having their first dose it's not just
about the mega sites it's also about
bringing the vaccine closer to the
people
in this community
health officials say they want residents
to take advantage of the vaccine clinics
around them
while they're operating now appointments
are required for this
vaccine drive up clinic but watkins will
be
welcomed but it's not guaranteed that
you will be vaccinated if you do walk in
reporting live victoria saha 8 news now
thank